when you meet someone remember they may
not know exactly what you said to them
or whatever or they may not remember
specifically that but people always
remember how you made them feel keep
that in mind when you're meeting people
and I try and keep that in mind when
meeting everyone because I've met a
couple of my heroes and they were back
in the day and they weren't exactly like
all that I had dreamed them up to be and
I would never want that to be the case
for anyone that got to meet me because I
may only meet them once and nobody knows
what anyone's going through and
everybody's a story and everybody's
having a tough day sometimes and so
confession